what's the number one thing you want
everyone in this room to walk away with
that I think there's literally 300
million different ways to win in the
u.s. if that's how many people we have
right like that there is no blueprint
there is no exact way it only comes down
to being able to factor in the 40 or 50
indexes input points context points
around your life and then navigating
through that and so what what I really
want is for people to understand don't
do it like me don't do it like you don't
do it like sucks they'll do it like
traps they'll do like Cuban like spend
as much time as you can and Steph I'll
be honest with maybe you know the answer
I'm actually merely asking you if I knew
how to help people like create more
self-awareness it's what I would sell I
don't know if that becomes through
therapy or some system or I don't know I
really don't my fear is actually the
reverse in terms of with all of the
information with all the self-help with
all the people on Instagram saying these
three easy steps
the fear is we are telling people as
soon as you have a job that you if you
have a job that you like click and when
you meet a man that you like click and
then you could afford a house and then
you have a baby all of these things are
the recipe for success well if you're
using some sort of Cosmo checklist for
the recipe for success you are going to
end up very unhappy because success is
internal so I'll go a different way find
but I actually think we're in a much
better place than we've been for the
last 60 years on this issue I because
prior to this world where we have so
many more opinions and platforms we had
three channels that told everybody that
thing there was three old white guys
that owned ABC and NBC and a great point
that completely pushed down to them what
it was supposed to be so now at least we
have a lot more voices and there's more
things to Namak